as the deadline looms tempers Run High
at the banks and at makeshift currency
swap centers too
with only a few days left maimunu Savio
traveled 30 kilometers to swap her old
naira notes before they ceased to be
legal tender she also wants cash to buy
her family's basic needs as businesses
have started rejecting the old notes
we too don't want to risk it we are
stuck with them and can either buy nor
sell
in October last year Nigeria's Central
Bank redesigned some of its currency
notes introducing more security features
it says the move was necessary but the
pain Nigerians go through is mounting as
Millions scramble to swap the old notes
an estimated 64 million Nigerians like
access to banking services most of them
live in rural areas like this where
there is none it's people like this who
stand to lose some or all their savings
when the deadline expires economies say
if that happens it could worsen the
poverty rate in a country where more
than 60 percent higher population live
below the poverty line
in Kano City the country's second
largest the queues at the banks and cash
dispensing machines are long leaving
many frustrated
I'm currently in debt right now I can't
withdraw money to feed my family I've
closed my shop for two days to look for
money to pay back my small debts and buy
food for my family so far I'm unable to
a problem that's even worse in crisis
hit Northeast and Northwest Nigeria
while Governors are worried that
millions of their people will lose their
life savings
you have only four local governments
that have Banks
even before that I'm mentioning the
capacity to satisfy the people is not
there
the central bank is scrambling money
deposit banks to the villages to ensure
Millions don't lose their savings
we took the step
one to the banks and specifically
instruct them to pay this money to
agents that would go back to these
communities and pay them
despite that residents of rural areas
here they could still lose their savings
like they did in a similar exercise 39
years ago
but in the capital Abuja where
monitoring the process is stricter the
complaints here of inadequate supply of
the new notes but the queues are short
it was easy because the bank has been
nice and the bank is nice to us they
encourages that you try to collect the
money confirm them and then pay into our
own accounts
a limited supply of the new nodes has
disrupted economic activities across the
country the parliament has asked for a
six-month extension but the central bank
is resisting which could mean more chaos
and losses for Millions already
struggling to feed their families Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera colonel